[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday November
27th this video comes in four parts
you're not the only one who could have
parts in his videos part one Eagle's
Nest camp I don't get an email from page
Lester now the director of Eagle's Nest
camp and I think that she wants the
nerdfighters to stop calling her she
wasn't overly explicit about this she
wasn't angry but she did mention that a
lot of people have been calling and
emailing about Tiffany with no last name
and that they can't share information
like that she also said that they were
trying to but couldn't respond to every
request individually that's very nice of
her
I remember page if you're watching hi
back when I was at eat as much she
wasn't the director of the camp you went
on a hundred mile hike on the
Appalachian Trail together
she was the counselor Iowa's camper it
was awesome Eagles Nest campus awesome
if anybody's looking for a summer camp
good Eagle's Nest camp Bart do the
bloggers Choice Awards John you and I I
don't know how I feel about this I've
won best video blogger and the Vargas
Choice Awards best video blogger that so
that feels good
our competition wasn't very stiff I
don't think the very many people knew
about the larvas Choice Awards but the
nerdfighters came through they give us
their time they clicked and we won and I
don't know what we get but we won so
hopefully we'll get it soon maybe it's
about time for me to get five hundred
arrows barn three shopping
I really appreciated all the comments on
my last video was nice to see everyone
kind of agreeing with me recently read
an article in The New York Times that
said that 80% of Americans wish that
Christmas was less materialistic and
that was the only part of the article
that didn't tremendously bismi off the
article is about how the mainstreaming
of green is taking Christmas away from
the people I'm not trying to take
Christmas away I'm trying to make
Christmas suck less
in fact I think they may have coined a
new term the green Grinch which is a
little bit ironic don't you think
because the Grinch was the person who
tried to ruin Christmas by taking away
the presents but when the presents were
gone the people were still happy because
they love each other and here's the real
kicker the point of the holidays for
many people is the joy people get in
giving sent Kenneth B green you're
quoting Kenneth P green John you don't
know who Kenneth P green is because
you're not a gigantic enviro dork like I
am but Kenneth P green and the American
Enterprise Institute are funded entirely
by billion-dollar corporations including
Exxon they don't
careful or happy as long as we're
spending our money how does this guy the
resident environment scholars you get to
quote on your article yeah you probably
could have found a lot of people to say
the same thing that he did but why him
this guy offered $10,000 to any
scientist who would come out and
disagree with the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change
he's bribing people to disagree with
global warming and the New York Times
was like well we need an environmental
scholar let's go to Kenneth Oh New York
Times I don't mean to push my values on
you but I really do believe that the
fathers of the world don't suffer for
lack of electric shavers and temperature
sensing barbeque forks and if anybody
kind of agrees with me on this stuff and
wants to think more about it Bill
McKibben who we've talked about a
brotherhood 2.0 before wrote a really
excellent article that I think kind of
hits all the bases on this stuff and I
don't do it over here or possibly down
there depending on where you are and
part for the scavenger hunt don't forget
to be awesome
John I'll see you tomorrow